What is Grids?
>> Okay, Grids,
um, so Grids is a protocol. Well, it
started as a protocol. It's kind of
expanded a little bit. Um,
it's basically a dead drop signature
protocol, uh, that allows you to have
data that needs to be signed,
have that held somewhere, and then have
a separate device, your wallet, um, or
like your phone or whatever. So you're
you're browsing on the internet with
your computer and now you want to log
into something or sign. You want to log
in requires a signature or you want to
transact with a blockchain requires a
signature. Same same type thing. Um the
thing that needs to be signed is encoded
with a location and that location can be
shown to your phone
visually through a QR code. the phone
can read that go out separately separate
device. So the phone doesn't know what's
going on necessarily. It just knows I
need to go get this thing to get signed.
Your keys are on your phone. Your
computer is what you're browsing with or
you got two phones or whatever. Um the
whole point is that we're separating the
execution context that you're you're
cruising around the internet with from
the signature context. We're going to se
physically separate them by device. Um,
that also allows us to do a bunch of
cool things like it doesn't matter what
kind of browser you're using anymore.
You could be using a mobile browser or,
you know, desktop browser. You could be
using a text browser. It doesn't matter.
We can show this information to your
wallet any number of ways. It just has
to be able to get hold of an address to
pull data from, sign it, and then puts
the data back in the same spot. That's
basically how the thing's defined. uh
and then the back end of whatever that
system is can go on with whatever it's
supposed to do. Um that's how we made,
you know, marketplace signatures work
snappy. That's how we've escaped from
this whole browser nightmare, the
security nightmare of the of the browser
context. We don't have we don't even
have a browser plug-in wallet anymore.
The whole idea is silly. Um so we just
got rid of the idea. Uh,